[Musique]
bonjour à tous le voici le premier grand
film de la rentrée les frères sister's
il s'agit d'un western entièrement
tourné en langue anglaise par jacques
audiard le parcours de deux frères tueur
à gages missionné pour retrouver un
homme et qui chemin faisant vont
revisiter les liens qui les unissent
l'aîné cdn cervelli également
coproducteur du film aussi à l'aise dans
des comédies comme ricky bobby ou bien
encore sous la direction de martin
scorsese gangs of new york
le cadet n'est autre que l'immense
joaquim phoenix de gladiateurs argo
online
on le sait capable de tout à l'ouest
enfin du nouveau rencontres de cinéma
aujourd'hui avec en anglais dans le
texte jacques audiard accompagné de ses
deux acteurs john terry et joaquim
phoenix
[Musique]
nous nous sommes donnés
faux
tout d'abord merci d'être parmi nous
pour votre nouveau film jacques les
frères sister's à l'origine c'était
votre idée john lorsque vous êtes
rencontrés il ya quelques années déjà au
festival de toronto
joachim merci de vous joindre à nous
donc c'était d'abord votre idée c'était
surtout l'idée de mon épouse allison
béquilles également productrice de ce
film elle travaillait déjà avec patrick
de 8
l'auteur du roman lorsqu'elle lui a
demandé si nous pouvions adapter son
livre avons ensuite proposé le scénario
à jacques comme cadeau tombé du ciel
et comme nous souhaitions éviter tous
les clichés qui collent au western nous
indique un regard européen était un bon
moyen d'éviter ces clichés
d'autant qu'à l'époque l'ouest américain
et et cosmopolite et peuplé de gens qui
venaient de tous les horizons
c'était donc tout à fait naturel jacques
vous avez été surpris par cette
proposition
oui oui bien sûr parce que commencer je
serais pas allée de moi même perdre un
western c'est parce que comment john et
alison m'ont donné le roman que je ne
les lui l'a fait c'est plutôt
l'entousiasme que suscité par le roman
le western vient presque au second tour
m
dans ce cas un peu déçu san joaquin
vous vous souvenez de votre première
réaction lorsqu'on vous a proposé ce
projet vous avez lu le scénario
qu'est ce qui vous a plu immédiatement
qu'est ce qui m'a plu immédiatement ma
dix ans que j'ai commencé par lire le
livre et j'ai trouvé l'écriture très
intéressante un mélange de mélancolie et
d'humour et chaque personnage était
défini avec beaucoup de précision donc
j'ai donc immédiatement pensé que enfin
vous savez la plupart du temps il est
assez difficile de dire précisément
pourquoi un projet vous étiez mais j'ai
eu vite le sentiment que le projet de
john était surtout de nous réunir tous
les et de nous voir jouer deux frères
j'ai trouvé que l'idée était assez drôle
parce que en fait il est tellement plus
petit que moi que je me suis dit que ce
serait marrant à regarder ce que j'aime
dans ce film c'est qu'il aborde
énormément de sujets et parmi tous les
thèmes explorés
vous êtes d'accord pour dire que le
sujet principal est la recherche d'un
peu plus d'humanité de quest for
humanity je crois que la deuxième moitié
du 19e siècle dans l'ouest américain
était une vraie période de transition
les gens commençaient à s'interroger au
sujet de la violence bien génocide de la
loi du plus fort et sur la nécessité de
continuer ou non à faire parler les
armes
les gens se sédentariser s'installer
dans les fermes des villes souhaitait la
sécurité l'apaisement et la question du
droit s'est imposé à ce moment là je
crois d'ailleurs que nous sommes
actuellement à nouveau dans une période
de transition
j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui nous
nous interrogeons
sur ce que nous voulons faire de notre
avenir en adoptant un point de vue plus
humain vous avez suivi une préparation
particulière pour jouer ce rôle
il y à un scénario un réalisateur des
partenaires bien sûr mais comment êtes
vous rentré dans votre personnage je
crois que tout d'abord l'essentiel était
d'établir une bonne relation entre john
et moi que nos personnages parce que
plus clair de leur temps ensemble ils
dorment même l'un à côté de l'autre
c'était donc le duo qui était essentiel
et puis par ailleurs se familiariser
avec les costumes et les chevaux c'était
ça aussi le plus important étant donné
qu'ils passent leur journée à cheval et
john et moi étions un peu intimidés par
les armes et jusqu'au dernier moment
nous étions carrément nerveux à l'idée
de tirer avec ses pistolets c'est
d'ailleurs presque ce qui nous a pris le
plus de temps que nous habituer à porter
avec naturel c'est revolver à la
ceinture
toute la journée on se demandait s'ils
ont dégainé assez vite et on avait aussi
peur du bruit
d'ailleurs au début on tirer comme ça
c'est aussi un grand film à propos de la
famille famille je t'aime famille je te
hais
ça parle de la difficulté de coexister
avec les siens au lycée la fratrie de
fratrie en fait je sais que parce que
les sujets se révèle on est très très
innocent quand on fait quand on choisit
quelque chose moi je voyais c'est cette
histoire l'ailé ces deux personnages me
plaisait il y avait ce côté picaresque
tout ça à tous et très spirituel et
qu'il y avait au fond du sujet quelque
chose que je ne peux que je n'ai pas
perçu sur le moment que j'ai perçu après
au long au montage c'est la fratrie de
la fraternité
qu'est ce que c'est qu'avoir un frère
comme on peut s'inverser une nes mais ça
voilà ça et tout à coup je crois que
c'était le sus était le sujet qui me
touche est finalement le western c'est
juste que le bac g
vous savez comment quand on est français
le western même si on joue aux cow boys
indiens quand on est quand on est petit
c'est une culture d'importation ce n'est
pas notre culture ça n'est pas
fondateurs comme ça peut l'être pour
pour les américains donc pour moi j'ai
toujours vu dans ce film là un film
d'époque et d'une époque très
intéressante au rouge
[Musique]
pourquoi vous avez tourné en roumanie et
en espagne plutôt qu aux etats unis
c'est parce que je veux comme enjeu je
veux dire il ya deux raisons parce qu'on
a repéré en alberta on a tout fait c'est
tout existe en alberta vous avez les
tous les tous les décors sont là les
clés sont sur les portes il ya le grand
ciel il ya la chaîne de montagnes de 12
matchs tout a été filmé tout a été que
les tout tout a été
comment répéter donc je et donc il ya ça
il ya bien sûr la forcément le poids
d'une production américaine que j'avais
pas du tout envie de subir
et puis je me suis dit tiens voilà qui
quitte à faire quitte à faire de western
autant fabriquer notre outil de notre
outil de cinéma oui j'ai lu vous aviez
dit à jacques que vous n'étiez pas un
acteur professionnel qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire par là que chaque film est
un nouveau départ que vous recommencez à
0 sans méthode ni recette ni truc
d'acteurs alors je suppose que oui
en fait je ne sais pas vraiment ce que
je voulais dire je crois qu'il s'agit
surtout pour moi d'explorer ou de
découvrir à chaque fois quelque chose
d'inédit quelque chose d'inconnu
de nouveau je crois que parfois les
acteurs professionnels arrivent sur un
plateau et il suffit de leur demander
d'être en colère pour que il joue la
colère mais moi ça ne marche pas sur
l'amour est le claj aimerait ça
faciliterait pas mal la vie de mes
partenaires
il faut que je travaille bon je vais me
professionnaliser promis s'il te plaît
surtout pas compris jacques dès les
premières images du film on voit une
fusillade un cheval en flammes qui
galope dans la nuit c'est essentiel pour
vous de camper très vite les références
au western pour mieux ensuite passer à
autre chose mais c'est très intéressant
de savoir quelle est la première image
du film
qu'est-ce qui va fixer le plafond et le
seuil aussi bien dans son sujet dans les
thèmes que formellement et je crois que
c'est ça les dix premières minutes du
film tente de faire ça et ça s'est passé
alors donc oui là dedans il ya sébastien
d'accord mais c'est en même temps il ya
une espèce de conception un peu
surréaliste de lima et puis surtout
voilà c'est pas tant un western qu'un
compte s'il ya un film de référence pour
pour pour moi pour nous c'était le
commando était la nuit du chasseur de
l'automne donc il n'est pas un western
et que je pense que jusqu'à un certain
point l'image du début est une image qui
pourrait dans la nuit du chasseur
cette idée qu'il s'agit avant tout d'un
western est presque hors sujet aussi
réducteur que de considérer des films
comme french connection et le faucon
maltais
comme nos simple polar alors qu'ils ne
sont surtout pas que des polars qui
définit un western il n'y a même pas de
trop dans notre film même pas de cow boy
il ya des armes il ya des chevaux ils
font partie de cette histoire mais tout
réside dans la mise en scène on est
davantage dans un rêve de western que
dans un western c'est particulier de
travailler avec un réalisateur français
j'imagine que la nationalité importe peu
pour vous mais vous avez ressenti une
spécificité française ou européenne
non je ne crois pas pas vraiment je ne
sais pas vraiment quoi vous répondre je
veux dire par là que jacques est unique
donc je ne peux pas généraliser je sais
juste ce que c'est que de travailler
avec jacques pas avec un européen c'est
tout on va peut-être en rester là
je sais pas ce que ce que vous en pensez
les gars personnellement je vais vous
l'essayez merci beaucoup
ça lui bonne chance
maj fils merci beaucoup
là pas de problème avec plaisir allez il
était comme ça sur le plateau seulement
avec moi quel honneur
wickens bac es segré je suis très
honorée soit ou non non non non non non
ce n'était pas normal
qu'est ce que vous avez appris pendant
ce tournage jacques énormément de choses
à chaque fois ce sont les tendances très
différent bien sûr mais celui là qu'est
ce qui vous a amené c'est difficile on
est soi pas que je puisse en parler
maintenant ce que je sais c'est pas
parce que mes camarades de jeu sont là
c'est que j'ai eu un enthousiasme de
dans le travail avec eux ou le matin
j'étais très très transporté à l'idée de
les retrouver
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à vous en prie ou les
trois tous les deux à aa
merci beaucoup de jeunes merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]